all right voicemail real quick to 192
david p is our voicemail number here is
the guy formerly known as the get a life
guy who has an idea for what i should be
doing instead of hosting this show i
watched your show tuesday night man you
need to get a life you don't have a clue
about journalism i've called you before
yeah and you talking about take your
measuring that doesn't surprise me you
need to get a lot man maybe a shoe
salesman at Macy's or somewhere
have a good day I think I could do okay
as a shoe salesman at Macy's if that was
my next career yeah I remember that
infamous picture of you having your shoe
up on the desk there that kind of a lot
of attention people seem to like any
interaction I have to choose yeah okay
well there's one idea on the bonus show
today San Francisco is considering
charging proportional fines based on
income North Korea has a major crystal
meth problem we'll see what tax
involvement is in that story if any not
saying there is we'll just talk about it
on the bonus show and scientists have
completely eliminated HIV in living
animals for the first time ever all of
those stories and more on the bonus show
sign up at david pakman.com slash
membership and make a pledge at
patreon.com slash david pakman show